bonsoir serge coulombe
bonsoir est ce que le message pour vous
change quand même quand on parle de
l'emploi maximal qu'on amène cela dans
le mandat de la banque du canada est ce
qu'on envoie un message différent sur le
rôle et surtout sur le mandat au fait de
la banque du canada
oui c'est on est maintenant
dans les faits la banque du canada une
et quand du marché de l'emploi et des
secteurs de la production pour mettre en
oeuvre sa politique monétaire on choisir
les taux d'intérêt parce que les taux
d'intérêt ont pas eu d'impact direct sur
les prix l'étude pour que les taux
d'intérêt et un impact sur les prix il
faut que au préalable on touche la
consommation l'investissement la
production et l'emploi et donc c'est
pour cette raison que la banque du
canada dans le passé avec une cible
uniquement d'inflation même si elle se
préoccupait de l'emploi parce que
c'était plus facile à communiquer
maintenant
plus facile à communiquer parce que
l'inflation tout le monde connaisse
l'inflation voire les hausses de prix à
chaque fois qu'ils font leur épicerie à
chaque semaine bon alors maintenant on
rend explicite le fait qu'il faut tenir
compte des considérations du marché du
travail donc il va avoir un gland un
gain en transparence dans le sens où
est-ce que c'est écrit noir sur blanc
que la banque du canada 50 du taux
chômage et de l'emploi mais il va y
avoir probablement une paire en
simplicité de la communication
changer quelque chose dans les faits
serge coulon par exemple sur l'édition
que la banque du canada doit prendre en
2022 compte tenu de la route inflation
en ce moment et petit monsieur fillon
c'est difficile à savoir indien
changement dans la façon dont on
présente la politique mais notez que les
américains par exemple on toujours eu un
mode dual ou est ce qu on se préoccupait
et de l'emploi et de l'inflation mais
dans la pratique on a très souvent fait
les choses exactement de la même façon
auriez vous donc à mon avis c'est plus
une façon de communiquer qui a changé au
aujourd'hui et puis
on s'en va en terrain inconnu on va voir
où est ce que ça va nous mener moi j'ai
pas que ça soit plus compliqué à
expliquer il faut avoir des questions
par exemple on pourrait demander
pourquoi est-ce que vous augmentez pas
les taux les taux d'intérêts aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya des pénuries d'envoi le
marché de l'emploi est en surchauffe et
le taux d'inflation est au dessus de la
cible voyez vous donc ça c'est une
question est qui est pas facile à
répondre
ils y ont souvent que les très bonnes
raisons d'augmenter les taux d'intérêt
aujourd'hui est-ce que de maintenir le
taux cible à 2 % avec une fourchette qui
varie de 2 à 3% est-ce que ça c'était la
bonne chose à faire oui tout à fait et
on est un chanceux d'avoir une politique
monétaire qui qui a été aussi crédible
et particulièrement dans la situation
actuelle où pour la première fois en 30
ans le canada ainsi qu'une bonne partie
du monde
des problèmes d'inflation
alors quand la cible d'inflation de 2 %
est atteinte et elle est crédible elle a
un impact sur les anticipations
inflationnistes
les anticipations inflationnistes
deviennent ancrer un taux de 2 % est
présentement ça peut beaucoup servir le
canada d'avoir déjà des anticipations
inflationnistes ancré à 2% parce que si
les anticipations de vienne par exemple
avec une inflation de 3 % ça va avoir un
impact sur les taux d'intérêt les taux
d'intérêt vont augmenter de 3% l'an
passé de 15 à 7 portant et
d'où l'importance d'avoir un impact sur
les anticipations d'inflation parce que
même la plus grande crainte vis-à-vis de
l'actuelle inflation au canada c'est que
elle change les anticipations
inflationnistes
heureusement la cible d'inflation de la
banque du canada est là pour garder les
anticipations et doris km on protège de
rien les gens avec une cible d'inflation
de 2 %
oui oui oui et on protège bien également
le marché de l'emploi pour le désert
auparavant maintenant on met juste des
points sur les i on change la façon de
communiquer la politique ok sks que donc
faut s'attendre compte tenu qu'on essaie
de ramener la décision d'aujourd'hui ce
qui est annoncé dans le réel c'est à
dire dans ce qu'on vit présentement un
taux d'inflation de 4 7% et même d'un
peu plus de 5 % au québec puis aux états
unis on est même rendu à 6,8 7% est-ce
qu'il faut donc s'attendre à des hausses
de taux assez rapide à partir de 2022
oui moi mon impression c'est que ça vaut
partir des états unis il ya déjà des
pressions très fortes aux états unis
comme à l'intérieur même du parti
démocrate pour faire augmenter les taux
d'intérêt ne sait pas où et parce que
l'inflation est devenue la préoccupation
économique numéro un aux états unis et
une fois que laquelle le bal des hausses
des taux d'intérêt soit parti aux états
unis la banque doit avoir beaucoup plus
de marge de manoeuvre pour elle-même
augmenter les taux d'intérêt mais c'est
clair qu'il faut s'attendre à des
hausses de taux d'intérêt
si l'inflation continue à perdurer en
début de 2022 et je pense que le
consensus présentement c'est que
l'inflation devrait perdurer également
en 2022 ok c'est ce que nous allons voir
merci analyse très clair serge coulon
merci bien merci bonne soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne i cirdi
oh